right it's pretty obvious that the biden
doj is attempting to prevent donald
trump from ever even running for
president again instead the new fishing
expedition is driving up enthusiasm
guess what among conservative voters
just in time for the midterms look at
this key race in pennsylvania between
washington outsider dr mehmet oz and
lifelong part-time government workers
trust fund brat john fetterman this guy
by the way never had a real job in his
life it's now drawing national attention
fetterman is the guy in the tattoos and
the hoodie never worked a real job in
his life he lived off mommy and daddy as
a real trust fund brat he apparently
paid one dollar to buy his home from his
own family he is a devout bernie sanders
loving socialist who by the way said
what bernie wants to do to the country i
want to have happen in pennsylvania he
wants to legalize heroin supports
abortion until the moment of birth no
restrictions
he also wants to release murderers and
rapists from jail in order to reduce the
prison population by a full third he
supports the radical green new deal
bernie supports him aoc supports him
elizabeth warren supports him he wants
massive tax hikes he's against fracking
oil and gas exploration in the keystone
xl pipeline that is an 80 billion dollar
industry of high paying career jobs in
the energy sector in the state of
pennsylvania and he wants he wants to
wipe all of it out and then he wants to
weaponize the federal government against
you the american people and american
businesses and unfortunately fetterman
recently suffered a debilitating frankly
crippling stroke and has been physically
and mentally unable to campaign in fact
he's only campaigned in person for a
total of 15 minutes since winning the
democratic nomination including a very
short very confusing and frankly very
sad five-minute speech from earlier
today take a look
let me ask you a question if you
say
you think the word
of
steelworker
what words come to your mind if you say
steel workers you know what comes to my
mind also is making sure that i'm going
to be proud to stand and defend the
union way of life here if i make it to
dc being anti-union
is anti-american
what is wrong with demanding for
an
easy safe
kind of
their
income
a path to a
safe place for them to win
excuse me to work thank you thank you
for endorsing me
on first day of my
campaign
that was a little over four minutes and
that was it as of now the fetterman
campaign is refusing to debate dr oz
also refusing my invitation to appear on
this program as he and his campaign have
been lying about me raising money off of
my name he apparently sent yet another
fundraising text today attacking me
lying about me calling me a liar every
day he lies about me i'll continue to
tell the truth about his radical extreme
positions way out of touch with the
hard-working people of pennsylvania and
by the way uh my trust fund brat friend
when you attack me i will attack you
back 10 to 100 times harder because
you're a lying loser and raising money
for your losing campaign he may be
hearing from my lawyers very shortly he
better hope that mommy and daddy have
enough money to pay his legal bills
anyway either way it does appear that
the socialist is mentally unable to
debate and if you're watching from
pennsylvania tonight i want you to think
about this if fetterman is too weak to
do an interview with little old me how
on earth is this guy going to stand up
for you in the senate he won't debate dr
oz uh yet he just sends out tweets and
fundraising letters that's it he's
campaigned a total of 15 minutes that's
it in the entire
general election campaign uh you can't
be senator if that's all the time you're
going to give the people in your state
here with reaction arkansas gop
gubernatorial candidate in our own right
sarah sanders is with us and along with
fox news contributor laura trump sarah
we'll start with you get your take on
this race um
if if you say in pennsylvania that you
want to support bernie sanders and what
bernie wants to do for america you want
to do for pennsylvania and you want a
moratorium on fracking in all energy
production which is 80 billion dollars
for that state and you support abortion
with no exceptions at all up to the
moment of birth i don't think this guy
is too in touch with the people of
pennsylvania
i don't think he's too in touch with
anybody
it is absolutely absurd
that this is the democrat candidate for
the u.s senate in pennsylvania
but i think he encapsulates everything
that is wrong with the democrat party
right now and you have a party that is
moving every single day further and
further to the left this is no longer
biden's democrat party this is
bernie sanders and aoc's party just look
at what we're expected to see tomorrow
coming out of the white house with a
complete and total wipeout of student
loan debt and forgiveness of student
loans it's going to make inflation worse
and frankly they don't care because it's
a blatant attempt to buy votes and they
are looking to do things that will help
them in november because they know that
the policies they've enacted over the
last year and a half have caused us to
have a recession they've put a absolute
turmoil on our southern border and every
single thing they touch they're
destroying so now they have to look at
how they can buy votes through programs
like student loan forgiveness but they
just keep moving to the left and the
only good thing is that that further
fires up republicans to turn out and
show them the red wave that's coming in
november and gives us greater reason to
make sure we get strong conservatives
elected
you you're gonna you will be a great
governor probably the best governor in
the history of arkansas and there's
another guy that stole your last name
that was once governor there
laura i'm watching pennsylvania for
example it reminds me of joe biden
hiding in the basement the media running
defense for in this case fetterman he
hasn't answered a single question he has
the most radical positions
we can't allow that to happen that
didn't work out well with biden did it
it certainly did not work out well for
americans whenever you have somebody
able to hide away not answer questions
campaign out of a basement um and gosh
that video you played of him honestly is
very concerning i truly hope that he
gets the help that he needs but sarah's
exactly right pay attention america
because this is what the democrats want
these are the kind of people that they
want elected and representing you in
washington d.c if they get their way and
with 75 percent of americans right now
saying that we are on the wrong track as
a country first of all i'd like to ask
to 25 what's going so great for them we
cannot afford to have anyone close to
this representing pennsylvania or any
other state in the senate right now
things are so bad in america and gosh
isn't it so insulting to see the
democrats and joe biden come out and
tell us what a great job they've all
done that they have made our lives
better that inflation is zero percent it
is an absolute insult to americans and i
think sean that people get it people
feel it every day they know they're
worse off they know that not only are
things more expensive we're poorer as a
country right now most people thanks to
biden and the democrat policies just
like people like john fetterman want to
put in place
and the only way we are going to get our
country back is if we get out and vote
we know how to turn it around vote in
republicans vote out establishment and
democrats that's what we have to do on
november 8th by the way laura i hope
everybody hears you loud and clear and
especially vote if you're in arkansas
because your new governor is right there
in the middle of your screen yes all
right thank you thank you both